[Music]
you're watching reason live streaming to
you from Los Angeles the following is a
live conversation between the host the
guests and the online audience if you'd
like to participate please leave your
question in the YouTube chat the views
expressed by guests and the audience
members in this discussion do not
necessarily reflect those of reason and
now your host Zach Weissenberg hello
thank you for joining us for day three
of this live stream experiment today
we're going to be talking with Rick
Doblin
of maps the multidisciplinary
Association for psychedelic studies and
if you've heard anything about
psychedelic science the medical use of
psychedelics to treat things like PTSD
or drug addiction most likely Maps has
had a hand in it they've been at this
since the 80s just plugging away and now
a lot of this stuff is just starting to
come to fruition we're seeing MDMA in
Phase three FDA clinical trials and many
other exciting things that we're going
to talk with Rick about so start asking
your questions now because I really want
this to be this entire endeavor is meant
to be an interactive experience but
especially this one I think people out
there if you can come up with good
questions this this is prime for for
interaction so we'll talk with Rick in
just a second just to give you a preview
of what's coming up on Thursday and
Friday tomorrow we're going to be
talking with Christian O'Brien he is a
writer and creator of the 1791 L YouTube
channel which is a couple of young
conservative libertarians who put out
some really interesting stuff and we're
gonna be talking a little bit with him
about the future of the write and what
it's like to be an independent content
creator in the currents climates and
that that should be pretty interesting
so if I do encourage
you if you're going to join that
conversation go head over to their
YouTube channel 1791 l and take a look
at a couple of their videos and come
loaded with questions for a Christian
and then on Friday as I've mentioned on
every stream so far we're gonna be
bringing on reasons own nickel SP to
touch again on a topic that we touched
before which is post-modernism which has
gotten oh it's there's been a kind of
resurgent interest in that topic that
was hot in the 90s and it's hot again
for some reason and we're gonna we put
out a video about that and we got some
interesting responses that we want to
reply to and just solicit more responses
as well in in real time and if you want
to send to questions in advance about
that or for Christian you can send an
email to questions at reason.com and now
let's get right into this conversation
with Rick who's standing by we're going
to I'm gonna start this off with a clip
we I attended with my recent colleague
Alex Manning in 2017 the psychedelic
science conference in San Francisco and
this brought together researchers from
around the world who were studying
psychedelics particularly in a medical
context and I it it blew my mind it
really did and this is the documentary
that we came away with or just a little
clip just to give you a sense of what
they are doing and what the promise of
this is so we'll play that and then
we'll come right back with Rick Doblin
there's so many ways to answer the
question why explore psychedelics these
drugs get deep into the psyche I think
the value of psychedelics lies in their
potential to be effective treatments for
patients who were not responding to
conventional treatment we should
recognize human beings have an urge
changed consciousness I often think
about it in terms of Dorothy's trip to
Oz the laws about many substances were
passed with total disregard for the
evidence so now we're at the stage if
there's more psychedelic research at any
time in the last 50 years alright so
that was just the intro Rick welcome to
the stream thank you for having me and
that was your voice at the end saying
that there's more psychedelic research
now than there has been in the past 50
years
what can you just tell us about that and
and how we arrived at this moment well
there isn't a psychedelic Renaissance
that's taking place not just in the
United States but all over the world and
how we got here basically from the 50s
and 60s there was an incredible interest
in psychedelic research and it was not
controversial it was happening all over
the world it was seen as one of the most
important new advances in psychiatry it
really helped lead to the discovery of
neurotransmitters in the brain because
people started wondering how did
something as small as LSD have such a
profound effect but then it also got
tangled up into the counterculture and
particularly in the United States with
psychedelics being connected to a lot of
people who were really protesting the
Vietnam War who were supporting
environmental movement women's rights
movement civil rights movement and for
political reasons President Nixon sort
of tried to clamp down and pass the
Controlled Substances Act of 1970 and
that basically wiped out psychedelic
research in the United States and also
we through our exports we our exporting
drug policy we wiped it out all over the
world
and there was nothing for several
decades and then where we are today
really began in 1992 with the FDA
formally saying that they were going to
reopen the door to psychedelic research
in 1990
they gave permission to Rick Strassman
to do a study with DMT and then in 1992
Charlie Grove who is also one of the
voices in your documentary he and I were
able to get permission to start research
with MDMA but it was really the FDA and
some people there that said it was time
for science really to be conducted and
time to overcome this political
resistance and so ever since 1992 we've
been able to do this research and the
other big thing that it's really been
dependent on is private donations
because we've had what you might call a
market failure in the sense that the
major psychedelics are off patent in the
public domain
pharmaceutical companies we're not
interested in working with them also
pharmaceutical companies really don't
understand psychotherapy and these were
drugs that worked in combination with
psychotherapy and so the National
Institute on Drug Abuse the National
Mental Health NIH there's no funding
available from those organizations major
foundations we're not supporting this
sort of research and so maps which I
started in 1986 and then a group called
heffter Research which was started in
1993 right after the 92 meetings with
FDA and then Beckley foundation in
England started so it's really been
through the donations of individuals and
family foundations that we've been able
to sponsor this research and we're
hoping that there'll be more funding
from traditional sources but we are now
in this incredible situation of research
going on all over the world and the
other thing that I'd say really
contributed to this is the sad
development that that normal drugs from
Big Pharma have not been able to address
a lot of the mental health issues that
are out there in addiction in depression
and post-traumatic stress disorder there
are drugs that help to some extent that
there's a large number of people that
are we're called treatment resistant
that are that are not able to find the
relief that they needed but then I think
there's also been one other me
your factor which is spirituality and
that a lot of these psychedelics have
been used for thousands of years there
are some new ones like LSD that have
just come from the lab but suicide and
masculine from peyote ayahuasca from
plants in Brazil and South America that
these drugs have been used for thousands
of years for spirituality and healing
and some kind of combination of both of
them and I think a lot of what's been
happening with globalization with
modernity is that we've lost a certain
amount of faith and a lot of the
traditional religions and then the
traditional rituals and rites of passage
and they haven't had the power that in
the past they may have had for helping
people have these powerful experiences
that we all feel a need for this
connection to the larger world and
psychedelics have been able to provide
that for thousands of years and so
despite the efforts of government to
suppress this for decades it really was
not successful and now we have a
resurgence and in fact what we're trying
to do is really show that these drugs
these experiences are not linked to a
counterculture that they can be
integrated into the mainstream and
revitalize and I think that's really the
political challenge that we're facing
now as we move forward and we're very
close to medicalizing MDMA and other
groups psilocybin so it's a tremendous
moment of opportunity at a time of great
need yeah and you mentioned that the
government has suppressed tried to
suppress this for decades but it's still
persisted and and that's largely thanks
to maps and some of the affiliated
groups so a tip of the hat to you for
that and we want to and you know you
mentioned they were scientists were
studying this in the 50s and 60s and I
actually have some archival footage that
I came up with from the getting
acquainted
all the tests and examinations gonna
keep him busy for the whole week day and
night practically the second Monday we
give them a small dose of LSD in the
five-man Ward together this is to help
the group pull together and in their
group experience during his twenty six
days to also get some good from this
then the third Monday we give them a
larger dose individually and have each
one of them are cared for by one of
these teams who have associated with
them and they give them their complete
support and this is where we aim for the
so-called psychedelic experience
[Music]
that was obviously doctors administering
LSD to patients and what exactly you you
you said it was Nixon coming in in the
1970s and and cutting it off what kind
of research were they doing back then
did they make any breakthroughs back
then and did you just kind of you know
40 50 years later pick up where they
left off or did you go in a completely
different direction no problem well
basically we did pick off where they
pick up where they left off there were
there were major breakthroughs you know
in many ways as I said the discovery of
the neurotransmitter systems of
serotonin we're an outgrowth of the LSD
research LSD is very similar to other
substances that act on the serotonin
system but I think I would say that the
major breakthroughs were in the
treatment of addiction and in the
treatment of people who were facing
life-threatening illnesses who were
nervous or anxious or depressed about
dying and the results of those studies
were phenomenal
what people most people don't know is it
Bill Wilson one of the founders of AAA
actually used LSD and thought it to be
very helpful and thought that it would
be something that could play a role in
regular Alcoholics Anonymous and that
became controversial and he basically
had to leave AAA but there was
tremendous work with heroin addicts with
alcoholics and a whole range of
psychopathologies and psychotherapies so
these drugs were really the most
exciting things happening in psychiatry
in the 50s and 60s and it was only the
way in which they got tangled up in the
counterculture that they got
criminalized and then because a lot of
this research is complicated you need
control groups you need legal contexts
what happened was that the the
therapeutic use got driven underground
and so there was a long history of this
work being conducted still in
therapeutic settings despite the laws
but there was never any sort of overview
summary of the data it was really just
continually used by small groups of
psychiatrists and psychotherapists and
it was out of those groups then all
sorts of new drugs were developed
including MDMA and so that was developed
by Sasha Shogun and others working
closely with him particularly after 1970
when the Controlled Substances Act
criminalized a lot of drugs and then
people started tinkering with the
molecules to find molecules that were
similar but legal and would have
somewhat similar effects and so MDMA was
rediscovered in the middle 70s even
though it had been initially invented in
1912 by Merck and forgotten about they
didn't know what they had they tested it
only in animals and I think there was
also an incredible experiment that was
done in 1962 that was called the Good
Friday experiment and that was done by
Tim Leary at Harvard Walter pahnke was
his PhD student was a doctor and a
minister and that was an effort to look
at whether psychedelics could produce a
spiritual experience and they took
twenty divinity students into Good
Friday service here in Boston and the
minister was revered Howard Thurman who
was Martin Luther King's mentor and it
was in the basement Chapel xx divinity
students each got a pill half had
psilocybin have had placebo and nine out
of the 20 people had a mystical
experience and the eight out of those
nine had suicidal and so that experiment
really was considered to be the most
important experiment in religion and
mysticism that was ever conducted and I
was able to sorry for my dogs in the
background
and that was something that was blocked
in 25 years later in the middle 80s
during this period of time when it was
still impossible to do research I was
able to do what's called the follow-up
study and I tracked down the people that
were in the study and they reaffirmed
even in the midst of the Nancy Reagan
Ronald Reagan escalation of the drug war
that they had a genuine mystical
experience and also that it led them to
participate in some of the social
justice struggles of the day Timothy
Leary also did an incredible project
called the Concord Prison Experiment
which was one where they administered
psilocybin to prisoners in prison
shortly before they released in order to
try to see if they could reduce
recidivism and so that was a very
important study
unfortunately what they realized is that
it's not enough to help people have
profound experience you need a support
group once they get out of prison and at
that point in time the reaction against
Leary he was kicked out of Harvard in 63
right when they're doing that and I did
it roughly a 35-year follow-up to that
project
and sadly discovered that the results
were presented in a way that was
scientifically invalid and basically you
could say fraudulent and it didn't
really work because they didn't have the
support groups but but there was very
important research in all different
areas in the 50s and 60s and I think the
main thing that people learned was that
these are incredible tools dr. Stan Grof
who was the researcher from the Czech
Republic one of the early LSD
researchers what he said was that LSD is
to the study of the mind what the
telescope is to astronomy and the
microscope is to biology and I think
that was the the enduring legacy of the
research in the 50s and 60s is that we
had these tools to understand and reveal
the mind I mean a psychedelic mean
mind manifesting hmm and so it was only
inevitable that eventually these drugs
would come back into scientific research
yeah it's just fascinating to me that
there were all these promising little
seeds that never really got a chance to
sprout because of the drug war and then
you took that and applied a rigorous
first of all help people navigate the
regulatory maze and then applied this
this rigorous framework to it and really
the big breakthroughs we mentioned at
the top so far has been MDMA for PTSD
which is the seems to be the furthest
along at this point and I want you to
talk about that in in a minute
and this but first I want to play a clip
because what you're talking about here
is psychedelic assisted psychotherapy
and I want people to get an idea of what
that is by hearing some of the people
who are engaging in these studies talk
about it so this is another clip from
that same documentary from the
psychedelic science conference our group
at Harbor UCLA and other groups at
Hopkins and why you elsewhere also
throughout Europe are beginning to
demonstrate that some of the most
difficult patients out there do seem to
be manifesting a positive response
sometimes to only one treatment session
within the context of an ongoing
psychotherapy the thing that we're
talking about with psychedelics is a
whole different paradigm it's a
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy where
you only get the psychedelics a few
times one thing that helped me
understand the nature of what we're
doing is when I kind of stepped away
from the notion that they're really drug
studies we have the language and the
tools and the systems for studying drugs
but what we're actually studying the
therapeutic benefit in theory comes from
experiencing an altered state of
consciousness for a limited period of
time like everything is
falling apart my eyes are an electronic
microscope and I can see how the atoms
and everything I often think about it in
terms of Dorothy's trip to Oz there she
was in black-and-white Kansas going
along things seemed fine
but when she was suddenly transformed by
writing that tornado to Oz and landed in
the world of the yellow brick road in
Emerald City in a horse of a different
color and all sorts of interesting
characters she must have been changed
as a result of that experience but at
the end of the day there's no place like
home
and she comes back to where she started
in all the same people are there she's
back in her home in her own bed but you
can bet that she's been changed from
that experience of having been taught so
have you seen that in practice with
these trials this idea where you only
need to do it one or two times and then
the person is more or less recovered
from the condition we have seen that I
mean our standard model is three MDMA
sessions one month apart and those are
eight-hour sessions with a male-female
clarity but that's supplemented by 12
90-minute non drug psychotherapy
sessions three in preparation once a
week for the first MDMA session and then
three 90-minute sessions after each MDMA
session for integration but to just give
you an example one of the veterans that
was in our study that had the PTSD for
years and years after having served in
Iraq in just one session he was able to
be cured and what he said happened to
him was that while he was under the
influence of MDMA which reduces people's
emotional fear response to painful
memories that he realized that there was
something beneficial to him from having
PTSD and that that was a way in which he
was expressing his loyalty to the
friends of his that had died and he was
able to
there was this benefit to him that this
was an important expression of loyalty
and then he looked at himself from the
eyes of the friends of his that had died
and he realized that from their
perspective they would want him to live
that they no longer had that opportunity
to live they had died but they wouldn't
want him to waste his life in in
post-traumatic stress disorder and he
was disabled unable to work reminded
constantly of the fear the trauma the
the scary for April things that happened
that they would want him to use the
precious life gift that he had to live
as fully as he could and that the best
way he could show loyalty to his friends
had died was not to be disabled from
PTSD but to live as fully as possible
and then he said to himself all right
what do I do with the rest of my life
and in that moment he healed himself and
then he said to himself I'm actually
taking opiates for pain and I don't
think I'm really taking them for pain I
think I'm taking them for escape and I
don't need them anymore and I'm gonna
stop the opiates and then he said I
don't really need the MDMA anymore I'm
gonna stop that and I want to drop out
of the study I'm cured he said to him
it's entirely voluntary that you stay in
the study but would you be willing to at
least do the outcome measures at 2
months and one year and he agreed to do
that and at 2 months in one year he had
no PTSD he was below the level of
symptoms to be diagnosed as PTSD so I I
don't want to give everybody the
impression though that these are one
dose miracle cures this was a rare
circumstance most people need several
sessions but even then what we've shown
is that in our phase 2 studies where
we've worked with a hundred and seven
people and we do follow-ups at two
months after the last experimental
session and also one year after two
thirds of people who had severe chronic
treatment-resistant PTSD on average
two-thirds of them no longer have a
diagnosis of PTSD one year after the
last session
it's absolutely remarkable and a lot of
the one-third that still has a diagnosis
of PTSD you have clinically significant
reductions in symptoms so it doesn't
work for everybody but the psychedelics
in a very profound way in a relatively
short period of time can help people
reprocess reprogram their brains
actually in some brain scans that we've
been doing it demonstrates that people's
brains are rewired in certain ways away
from these hyperactive fear processing
centers of the brain and you can take
memories that are sort of stuck in
short-term memory it's like the trauma
is always about to happen or it's always
happening and people are always scared
about that but they can process them as
part of their life as part of their
history but put it into long-term memory
so there there are remarkable
therapeutic potentials from psychedelics
when combined with psychotherapy yeah
and I guess that is the paradigm shift
here is that in psychiatry right now
it's kind of like you get the
prescription for Zoloft or whatever and
then you're on that for the rest of your
life possibly and this is you know
whether it is two times or five or seven
the idea is eventually you might not
need it anymore because it's getting at
something deeper inside the brain or as
you're saying like rewiring you could
say that it's a fundamental differences
are you treating symptoms or are you
treating the causes and what we feel
with psychedelic assisted psychotherapy
is that we're actually getting down to
the cause the trauma and helping people
process that whereas most traditional
psychiatric medicines can reduce the
symptoms but they're just palliative
they don't address the causes you stop
taking the pills the problems come back
you get a bunch of side effects from the
pills themselves and so this happen
maybe helps it for the listeners to
understand why these psychedelics are
being developed by nonprofit
organizations as compared to for-profit
pharmaceutical companies because what
we're trying to do is make it so people
are independent of these drugs and in
the therapy that we do in short
intensive work to try to help people be
independent rather than try to give them
drugs that are just palliative for
months or years or lifetime and you you
mentioned earlier the early studies that
we're studying kind of the the religious
experience or spiritual experiences that
people have under these when they take
psychedelics and there's a question here
about that from el Silva who asks why do
psychedelics mostly create mystical
religious like experiences do we have
any do you have any insight on that
question have we found anything
scientifically yes well one of the
things that has changed since the early
work in the 50s and 60s is the
incredible advance in technology for
brain scans and all sorts of ways in
which we can have a better understanding
of what the psychedelics do in the mind
when they're actively doing it and so
one of the big discoveries has been
through what's called the understanding
yeah this is actually what I was going
to talk about so what's called the
default mode network it's basically the
resting state of your brain and the
default mode network is is somewhat
equivalent to what we might know
psychologically is the ego it's like
what do we need for our own survival for
our own work for our relationships for
you know so we're sort of scanning the
environment for how does it relate to us
as an individual in this body at this
time and what that does is it's a filter
of all the information that's coming in
to us from all of our senses and from
all of our unconscious and that's
filtered for sort of our ego what do we
need to do for our own personal benefit
you could say and what the classic
psychedelics MDMA does not do this but
the classic psychedelics like LSD
psilocybin mescaline ayahuasca ibogaine
they reduce activity in the default mode
Network in the filtering system of the
brain
and so you get a broader flow of
information into your awareness and what
it also does if you think about it as
there's a membrane between the conscious
and the unconscious mind and at night
and dreaming we all have this weakening
of the membrane that that more
unconscious material fears emotions
ideas come to the surface in dreams in
imaginative ways and then when things
could get difficult then people can you
know emotionally difficult people wake
up with psychedelics that it has that
same aspect stan grof again mentions
that LSD is a nonspecific amplifier the
unconscious that it just brings what's
emotionally most relevant to the people
at the time in this kind of inner
healing intelligence wisdom process of
what comes to the surface of awareness
but you can't wake up I'm just like you
dogs you have to learn how to process it
and so we have a pretty good
understanding of how psychedelics work
what we don't really know is you know
why does certain emotions or certain
ideas or certain memories come to the
surface at any particular time there's
this understanding that we all know that
our bodies are self-regulating
self-healing systems that physically we
get hurt our body repairs itself and
there's some kind of similar mechanism
in the brain in the psyche and the ego
in the mind that that emotionally that
that somehow or other there's a
self-healing mechanism in the brain and
that there's this inner intelligence
about what we need to deal with to
really process and to move that healing
and so so we have this sort of
supportive inner directed therapeutic
method in the sense that it's not
scripted what happens during an LSD
session or during an MDMA session we
support what's emerging and we have this
basic belief that there is this kind of
inner healing wisdom and we support
what's coming up and so we know also
physiologically very precisely which
receptor sites in the brain which
classic psychedelics act on it's the
serotonin 2a receptor sites that
produces a lot of the visual effects and
also produces this flow of imagery and a
different way of processing there's been
incredible work with MDMA with brain
scans and so we know it acts differently
than the classic psychedelics and what
it does is it reduces activity in the
amygdala which is the fear processing
part of the brain it increases activity
in the frontal cortex which is where we
think rationally and logically and it
also increases connectivity between the
hippocampus and the amygdala which is
where memories are moved out to from
short-term to long-term storage which is
the opposite of what PTSD does PTSD
reduces activity in the frontal cortex
so we don't think as logically it
increases activity in the amygdala where
so people's fear reactions are hyper
stimulated and also it reduces
connectivity with long term memory of
the hippocampus and the amygdala so MDMA
in a way reverses the kind of brain
changes that PTSD produces in PTSD
sufferers it also stimulates the hormone
oxytocin and prolactin which are
hormones of nursing mothers of love of
bonding and it stimulates serotonin
dopamine and norepinephrine so I think
we have an increasingly good
understanding of what psychedelics do in
the brain and in the whole system and
that helps people to understand when we
say that these have such incredible
therapeutic potential we're able to also
use brain scans to demonstrate how
people's brains function before and
after treatment it's yeah it's a
fascinating time for this to be
happening because back in the 50s and
60s we didn't have all the tools of
neuroscience that we have now and that
that slide that I put up earlier right
here is from the
Beckley foundation in england and one of
the professor who conducted that study
is dr. David Nutt who happened to be the
former drug czar in England who had a
change of heart so that he has an
interesting story I'd love to get him on
the livestream at some point but I
interviewed him at the conference as
well and he had some things to say about
psychedelics and the study of things
like creativity or consciousness itself
and so I want to play just a little bit
of professor Nutt and then have you talk
a little bit more about those topics and
they can be disrupted by LSD when an LSD
basically makes the brain much more
connected parts of the brain which
haven't been allowed to talk to each
other for 30 40 years can talk to each
other again huge amount of crosstalk so
we call this the entropic brain or the
much more flexible brain and and we
think that's what underlies the
experiences that people have during the
trip we've got good evidence for that
but also he explains why afterwards
people often feel different and better
because they've been allowed to actually
the brains been allowed to work in a
slightly different way for the first
time perhaps ever so who ever thought
that these drugs which were portrayed as
just things that hippies do would
actually be able to be used by
scientists who study things like
different states of consciousness and
obviously treating the the maladies
we've been talking about I mean what
what kind of potential do you think they
have in that realm of of looking because
it's interesting that we're talking
about this on a live stream because you
know it's almost like I could put some
sort of different encoder on this stream
and you would see the stream coming
through and a pixelated weird way and
that's kind of the same way
consciousness is it's the stream and
then the psychedelics are the disrupter
there and that seems to open up some
research opportunities Oh an enormous
amount of research opportunities you
know back in the 8th
in the late 80s early 90s when after
MDMA was criminalized there was a lot of
concern about supposed brain damage and
the effect on the serotonin system and
the only way that we could really look
at it at that point in time was through
spinal taps was trying to look at
serotonin metabolites and other
neurotransmitter metabolites in the
spinal fluid so I've actually gotten two
spinal taps to look at my own brain and
also recruited about 30 other people to
do some of these spinal tap studies and
you know they're not as precise or as
accurate as the modern brain scan
studies you know there's going to be a
project at Yale that's actually going to
take PTSD sufferers give them MDMA and
stick them in a brain scanner and then
expose them to what's called a trauma
script of their trauma and a neutral
script and see how they process that
information so we had healthy volunteers
have taken MDMA and got into brain
scanners and we've scanned people with
PTSD before and after a therapy with
MDMA but there's never been the
opportunity yet but there will be soon
at Yale to take people who have PTSD
give them MDMA and stick them in a
scanner and see how acutely they
actually process information and
emotions in a different way and then
maybe they'll even learn something that
will help us improve how we do therapy
I think there's been incredible
studies one of the favorite ones that
I'll mention is in Switzerland and it's
taking lifelong meditators Zen
meditators and what they do is they go
to the University of Zurich for brain
scans to see how they process and see
how their brains work when they're
meditating then they go to a six day
meditation retreat at a place called fel
Center and Lucerne and during that
retreat in the middle of that they get a
pill and it's either psilocybin or a
placebo and they take that while they're
meditating and it's a significant amount
of it and then they're looking at it
afterwards - how did that affect their
meditation practice how did that affect
their altruism empathy
and they also go to brain scans
afterwards to see if there's any
permanent changes and how they process
emotions and thoughts so we're able to
actually start looking at spirituality
meditation therapy in ways that only
recently if we had these modern tools to
do so and so I think that if we really
can succeed in mainstreaming
psychedelics and we anticipate that MDMA
will be a medicine approved by the FDA
and in 2021
and we're anticipating for the european
medicine agency probably 2022 and other
groups are trying to do this for
psilocybin and so we think 2021 2022
psilocybin will be available and also we
look at ketamine ketamine is considered
one of the most important discoveries in
neuroscience and psychotherapy in the
last 20-30 years because ketamine is now
being used for depression it was an
anesthetic in the 60s but now it's being
used for a suicidal refractory
depression so there's great hope in the
therapeutic potential but also in really
understanding how they are processed in
the brain but I will say one thing
that's different between MDMA and the
classic psychedelics so in the work in
the 50s and 60s with LSD and psilocybin
for you know opiate addicts alcoholics
cancer patients in the current work with
psilocybin for a whole range of
addictions and depression and anxiety
there's a direct correlation between the
depth of the mystical experience and
there are therapeutic outcomes and we're
David Nutt was talking about a different
way of processing the brain is
connecting each other connecting parts
that weren't normally connected that
that that's the essence of the mystical
experience is a sense that that's all
connected we're all part of one larger
system you get out of your narrow ego
sense and you see this big sweep of
history of evolution we're all connected
in certain ways that the therapy is
often focused on helping people go to
beyond ego states of mine however with
MDMA which doesn't really dissolve the
ego in that way does
impact the default mode Network it just
reduces fear response to difficult
emotions that we use the same measures
of mystical experience and we find that
people do score fairly high with MDMA
but we found there is no correlation
between the mystical experience and
therapeutic outcomes for MDMA for PTSD
and I think why that is is that people
need to revisit the trauma from their
biography from a position of safety from
a position of being able to remember
bring repressed memories to the surface
look at them understand them not panic
from them and then put them into
long-term memory storage and so that's
where people need to be more grounded in
their MDMA experiences in their
biography and there's a different
therapeutic mechanism and MDMA by being
the most gentle of the psychedelics and
the most similar to normal processing it
just feels like people can process
clearer that it's the easier to
integrate it's the easier to take it
those lessons into one's daily life and
so because of that I think MDMA the
reason it's the first through the system
is because it is the gentlest and it's
the easiest for therapists and patients
to work with yeah and on the other end
of the spectrum and there's some
questions coming in about legalization
and what that pathway looks like and I
definitely want to talk about that in
just a minute but I want to ask about
one of the other studies that intrigued
me was had to do with psilocybin
mushrooms being administered to people
with a terminal illness and the findings
seem to be that it actually decreased
death anxiety could you just talk about
that finding and why you think that
might be happening yeah let me also say
that we were able to start LSD research
for the first time in 35 years and it
was in Switzerland that it was for
people with life-threatening illnesses
who were anxious about dying we were
also able to start research at Harvard
where Timothy Leary was and that was
with MDMA for Ken
patience with anxiety and so the
psilocybin work is part of that stream
of research to work with people who are
having a life-threatening illness cancer
and our anxious and fearful of dying so
I'd say the first thing that makes it so
therapeutic is that the fears and
anxieties that people have come to the
surface and you could work with them so
what we find is that those people who
have a life-threatening illness and have
depression or anxiety because of it
their focus of their attention is on
their illness and on what they're not
going to have the fact that they're not
going to be able to predict a long life
that they're going to have a shorter
lifespan what they've lost is what
they're focused on with the psilocybin
it helps them realize what they have now
that they're still alive and that they
could use their life as fully as
possible
also part of this mystical experience is
what's called the transcendence of time
and space the sense of being connected
to some sort of eternal thing now we
know this in physics we know energy is
not created or destroyed we know that
there's 13 14 billion years of history
that they were just here each of us
individually for a blip of time but we
get so wrapped in the present wrapped in
our mind and so under the influence of
psilocybin these cancer patients have
been able to both process the the fears
and anxieties about their illness but
also touch into the spiritual sense of
being part of this long sweep of history
and that's what's gives them a sense of
peace often and it also gets them into
the here and now so that in the here and
now they're alive in their minds they're
all thinking about what's going to
happen when they die they're gonna get
worse their illness is going to get
proceeding to get worse they're sort of
anticipating they're not living in the
present and if anything psychedelics
bring you to the moment hmm and so I
think that's a big part of their healing
potential and with psychotherapy those
experiences can have lasting impacts
only
one experience sometimes gives people a
new perspective and then they don't ever
forget that perspective and then there's
something fundamentally interesting that
I don't think we really understand fully
which is how these psychedelic
experiences are encoded in memory when I
did the 35 year follow-up to the Concord
Prison Experiment with psilocybin and
the 25 year follow-up to the Good Friday
experiment also with psilocybin people
had a very vivid memory of parts of
their psychedelic experiences after all
these years you know if I were to talk
to you about what movies you saw 25
years ago you know with even movies that
you loved you know
the memories of the psychedelic
experiences portions of them are just
intensely imprinted on our brains in
some ways that I don't think we really
fully understand yet but they have a
profound impact so when we think about
the work with psilocybin with death
anxiety I think it's got incredible
potential the hospice movement will
eventually be using psychedelics to help
people near the very end of life I think
when people are newly diagnosed with
life-threatening illnesses that would be
great for them to have a psychedelic
experience to prepare for the surgery or
chemotherapy or whatever they're gonna
get but also to help them with their
lives and then also we think about their
family members that it doesn't just
affect them it affects the people all
around them so you you said there are
some questions about legalization yeah
for medical use and non-medical use but
I think what we're gonna find is that
we're going to be working with patients
but we will then expand to their
families who are not technically the
patients but are still suffering and
then we'll expand into the larger
society yeah it seems as as if once this
evidence becomes more and more firmly
established these things it's just gonna
make sense to more and more people for
these things to be integrated into
society and mainstreamed as you put it
earlier and people are asking here how
you think that might play out one person
JSONP says what do you think the
possibility of recreational legalization
is and what
kind of positive or negative
consequences could have and then there's
another one down here there's a current
push to gather enough signatures for a
ballot initiative to move forward this
summer in Denver this is from case 12 to
decriminalize psilocybin and another for
the whole state of Oregon do initiatives
like this potentially reduce the
likelihood of the population accepting
the therapeutic benefits of MDMA and
other psychedelics so I guess that is
really the heart of both of these
questions is does recreational
legalization make sense or is that just
going to undermine all the work that
you've done to make this you know
medically acceptable well I think it's
interesting that we're having this
discussion today since yesterday the
Senate passed a major criminal justice
reform bill and hopefully the house will
pass it and President Trump will sign it
so I think what we've seen in general
over the last several decades is a
revaluation of the whole criminalization
of drugs in the drug war and that it's
been a resounding failure it's been one
of the most important failures in
American policy that we've exported all
over the world it's really been a
tragedy and so there's a revaluation of
that also going along with the
revaluation of the proper policy
structures for marijuana and so we see
growing acceptance of the legalization
of marijuana
now I've seen polling data that was just
sent to me the other day that had to do
with exactly what we're talking about
decriminalization or legalization of
psilocybin or other drugs and what it
turns out is that when you ask people
are you sympathetic with decriminalizing
drugs you'll get a majority roughly I
think it's about it was about 60% you
know right now it's about 64% for
legalizing marijuana but you talk about
decriminalizing
fines instead of jail it's around sixty
percent however when you ask the same
question but you put in the names of the
drugs are you sympathetic with the
decriminalization of drugs like LSD
heroin cocaine and
I am a roughly 20 points of support
drops away so when people anchor in
their minds to specific drugs they're
less willing to support
decriminalization so what I think that
means in terms of the initiative in
Denver the initiative in Oregon to try
to focus specifically on psilocybin that
those are not going to pass and that
there's not enough support for them the
other thing so I think that at least
initially I think broader D creme for
all drugs you might think that's more
controversial and less likely to succeed
but I think it's actually more likely to
succeed so I'm very sympathetic more
with broad decriminalization and I think
that when you target specific drugs
particularly psilocybin or LSD or MDMA
that the support drops way down now the
thing about marijuana what has happened
with marijuana is that we have had
roughly 22 years since 1996 which was
the first state medical marijuana
initiatives in California in Arizona
and we've had a preceding 22 years has
been the expansion of medical use of
marijuana with Medical dispensaries for
marijuana people can see that you can
regulate them in different ways and
they're not violence-prone the societies
don't crumble the drug use by young
people doesn't go up it's just been a
roughly several decades of
medicalization that has caused people to
see these drugs the risk benefit ratio
in different ways and to come to
different conclusions about how the
proper policies should be so I think
that what we need to do is medicalize
psychedelics for 10 or 15 years before
Deak remor legalization of those drugs
specifically will be past that there'll
be majority support for that so what we
anticipate is 2021 we get medical use of
MDMA then we're gonna set up thousands
of psychedelic clinics throughout the
United States where people are going to
be able to go for MDMA eventually
psilocybin ketamine what other drugs
hopefully I've
for the treatment of opiate addiction
will follow on and we'll be able to
really start helping people understand
that the residual fears that they have
that they've been told from decades and
decades decades and billions of dollars
of anti-drug propaganda that that is not
really the full story and I think so my
sense is that the efforts to do
initiatives for suicide are not going to
hurt our work at all in fact they'll
help it even that when they fail because
they're they're trying to raise a
conversation about these drugs and the
value of these drugs and they also make
it so that medicalization then becomes
not the farthest out thing it's now more
conservative we're now the conservative
wing of this drug reform movement
because we're just talking about
medicalizing and doing the science and
working with fda you have all these
people that are trying to decriminalize
so I don't think it'll hurt I think
it'll help but I do think that it's not
likely to pass and what we really should
be focusing on from a political
perspective is building on the support
for legalization of marijuana the
criminal justice system reforms that are
going through focusing not on prevention
through criminalization and fear but
through honest drug education and
support for treatment on demand and I
think that those are those shifts that
we're going to be seeing over the next
decade or two with drug policy
yeah and in addition to if you're the
conservative wing and the D crimpy Pilar
the progressive wing this man that I'm
about to show clip of might be the
radical wing George Burke who micro
doses LSD thus I become more of it and
he's open about it this has become an
emerging trend in places like Silicon
Valley and and Silicon Valley is is
known for experimentation with
psychedelics Steve Jobs famously said
that without LSD there might be no Apple
so I wanted to show this clip about
micro dosing and then get your thoughts
on what kind of the call
chiral elements of this is in terms of
mainstreaming acceptance of psychedelics
so here's just a clip from my interview
with George Bergman I decided to openly
talk about micro dosing because I had no
idea how positively it would have
affected my life
George Burk is a Silicon Valley
entrepreneur working in the field of
mind and body experimentation every
morning before he goes to work he
consumes a tiny bit of LSD about 1/10 as
strong as a typical dose with micro
dosing I don't really feel any effects i
I don't know that I've really taken it
other than I noticed that my brain seems
to be able to solve problems a little
bit better than I was before
Burke has calibrated his dose so that it
merely tweaks his perception and doesn't
interfere with everyday tasks he's part
of an increasingly popular trend called
micro dosing and I'm feeling a little
more connected both to my work and to
the people that I need to talk to on a
given day let me tell you about the
first time that I did LSD microdose I
had a big task I needed to take care of
putting together a large business
contingency plan it would have been
difficult to think about each
contingency and incubate it and put it
on paper this was going to be a very
large document that I was putting
together after micro dosing what I was
able to do and this just intuitively
came to me was to envision each
contingency as branches of a tree and I
could picture each one as a branch and I
could visually climb this tree and reach
out to one branch and grab that idea
incubate it write it down and then place
it back up and then go to the next
branch and I could do that all
throughout the entire tree and it was a
very interesting way to visually solve
what would have been a very complicated
problem to do otherwise
and I'll mention that micro there was a
micro dosing panel at the conference I
attended and it was probably the most
attended panel so there's a lot of
interest in this concept of just taking
a little bit to tweak your perception
rather than having an all-out trip so
what do you I guess what are your
general thoughts on micro dosing well
Albert Hoffman who invented LSD was
incredible man he lived to a hundred and
two
he died in 2008 and shortly before he
died he told me that one of the most
important areas of research with Elysee
that had not really been done was micro
dosing so he was very aware of the
different properties at different dose
levels and I think that there's a way in
which micro dosing can offer enhance
creativity we heard about the imagery
how people think it's just it's got a
Norma's potential there's people that
also use it for depression to just give
a little bit of energy but I think you
know those people that I know that do
that occasionally supplement that there
with large full doses to try to get to
get not so much at the symptoms but also
at the root causes but I think for
creativity when we look at what we think
is one of the main competitive
advantages of America around the world
is creativity it's free thinking and I
think that micro dosing really fits
right in to that and we also think about
Silicon Valley I mean it's very much a
popular substance used micro dosing in
in Silicon Valley but all sorts of
creativity artists you know I think it's
very brave for someone to say that they
do an illegal drug like that and be able
to be supportive you know promoted that
and you know I think the DEA at this
stage has got its hands full with the
incredible terrible opioid epidemic you
know last year more people died of drug
overdoses and one more Americans died of
drug overdoses last year then died in
the entire Vietnam Iraq and
the worst accidents so they're not
really going after micro dosers or
ayahuasca circles they've got you know
bigger problems and and so I think we're
able to have people step out without as
much fear to explain what they're doing
and I think that micro dosing is
definitely one of the most important
areas of of research and people are
getting a lot of benefits from it and I
think it's also from a society-wide
level there's been a lot of fear of that
losing control with LSD of letting the
mind go and micro dosing is a way to
help people go a tiny bit in that way
and and understand more how LSD works
you get a tiny bit of that direction the
Vantage of micro dosing too is that you
can learn how to do that on your own
without the drug - it gives it's
education that you can remember and
bring back to your daily life the same
way as in therapy we try to do a few
doses so you learn and process emotional
experiences but you don't need to keep
doing the drug I think a lot of people
find with micro dosing that it has
long-term effects even when they're not
micro dosing in terms of how to think in
a more creative way I will add that not
so much micro dosing but low doses of
MDMA we found paradoxically with PTSD
patients is not helpful in that it gives
them a stimulation but it doesn't reduce
the fear enough and so they actually are
very uncomfortable and people have
dropped out of our studies in the low
dose groups and so it really depends on
drug from drug to drug and also from
condition to condition healthy people
who you know do small doses don't have
to deal with that kind of trauma they
can they can be actually more open to it
I think it's an incredible area that the
sadness is that it's also been one of
those things suppressed for
decades and it's only now recently
becoming something that we're looking at
more incredible amount of lost potential
an incredible amount of unnecessary
suffering over the last couple decades
because of the drug war I'll just say
that reason has been so fantastic what
you guys do in terms of the drug war and
in terms of fundamental human rights we
haven't really discussed that but I
think that if you look at the Bill of
Rights and you look at the freedom of
religion the freedom of the press the
freedom of assembly that the freedom of
speech that underlying all of those is
the freedom of thought the freedom to
explore our consciousness and that the
drug war is a fundamental violation of
core human rights that we shouldn't
block people from having certain ideas
or certain experiences we should be
focused more on performance on how they
act and punish or reward accordingly
rather than on what drugs people ingest
or how they change their consciousness
and we actually if we look at the first
time that the sort of conquistadors came
into North America one of the things
that they did at the very beginning was
suppress the use of peyote so the drug
war isn't just started from Nixon in
1970 you know the drug war really began
at the very beginning of the
colonization of North America by going
after those people that use psychedelics
and also the longest-running mystery
ceremonies using psychedelics in the
history of the world that we're aware of
is the Ellis inian mysteries in Greece
and they went from around 1600 BC to
around 396 AD and they were wiped out by
the Catholic Church and they were
another way for people to have direct
access to spirituality and then you got
hierarchical structures that want to be
the mediator between you and God you and
spirituality and so the drug war has a
long history in Western culture and for
us now in this crisis stage of
globalization of global warming of
cultures coming together of the need to
move beyond fundamentalism these tools
that have been historically important to
us
but have been suppressed are coming to
the fore again at a time of great need
and I think we'll be able to
successfully use these to really help in
the struggle for human survival well
then I don't think we're gonna top that
you're talking about you know everyone's
heard of freedom of conscious and you're
talking about freedom of consciousness
which now is a beautiful note to end on
I think so
I want to thank you Rick Doblin for
taking the time to talk to us and
explain explain what is happening with
psychedelics it's an exciting few years
ahead it sounds like 2021 you mentioned
you expect MDMA might be on the market
to treat yeah PTSD and we'll see what
happens next and thank you to everyone
again who tuned in furthest we'll be
back tomorrow at our nighttime schedule
which is 7:00 p.m. Pacific 4:00 p.m.
Eastern with Christian O'Brien of 1791
el YouTube channel again I if you're
gonna tune into that I encourage you to
head over there and watch a couple of
their videos I think it'll enhance the
experience a little bit and we'll be
talking about the future of the right if
you have any questions for him ahead of
time or for Nicholas be about
post-modernism on Friday you can email
us at questions at reason.com
for now we'll head out and see you
tomorrow
Thanks
[Music]